hey guys I'm back and we're gonna be
talking about the four critical tips to
reversing a fatty liver
I've already did a complete video on a
fatty liver how to handle that I put the
link down below but in this video we're
gonna talk about bit for critical tips
okay and these are the points to
emphasize these are the most important
things in fact you gotta realize if you
have a fatty liver it's not just that
there's fat in the liver it's
dysfunctional the liver cells are
damaged okay and so we need to actually
fix that number one okay
organic the food that you eat must be
organic
why primarily because we don't want the
pesticide insecticide herbicide
fungicide those type of things right but
primarily the most commonly used
herbicide is glyphosate which is the one
they use in making GMO type foods and
it's in soy oil it's in so many foods so
what we want to do is we want to make
sure you don't we don't keep putting
back in that herbicide that glyphosate
that GMO food so that's one thing we
wanted to organic because if it's too
organic it doesn't have GMO and we also
want to detoxify the glyphosate and
other chemicals from the liver and
there's a compound called glutathione
okay and that's produced by the liver
it's also in certain vegetables these
vegetables will stimulate also the
production of of that compound to help
break down the chemicals and it's it's a
software-based compound and garlic onion
radish cruciferous parsley all those
really kind of pungent bitter vegetables
really good for the liver vital in fact
okay so that's number one number two is
keep your insulin really really low well
the the way that you got into this mess
in the first place is you you had the
insulin either too high or the fed liver
came from too much alcohol or out are or
other things that are related to that
maybe like some other types of junk
foods that you've eaten but mainly it's
the inside
in the alcohol so yes we need to cut the
alcohol out of the diet okay and we also
need to bring insulin down again I've
talked about this over and over I'm
gonna put another link down there if you
are new to this channel but insulin
needs to come down and we'd have to cut
out the sugar do in a minute fasting and
there's a lot of other things you can do
okay so that's number two because you
can't fix this with the high insulin
it's impossible choline is number three
choline is a B vitamin that is very
essential for dissolving or breaking
down fat from the liver it's called Lupo
trophic it breaks down lipids or fats
guess what food it's actually an egg
yolks it's in seafood wheat germ brussel
sprouts broccoli and other cruciferous
vegetables okay all right so you may
even consider just consuming this as a
supplement as well because we want to
get more of it right now just to really
break that stuff down now as these
chemicals are coming out of the liver
through the gallbladder out through the
intestine okay and the fats coming out
as well we better keep our vegetables
very very high because we want to
prevent constipation or any type of
backup so we want to keep the vegetables
high to start flushing all this fat out
and keep the system clean also this
overlaps because all the great
phytonutrients and liver supporting and
the factors that build up the liver
nutrition-wise are all in vegetables so
we have to consume at least six to ten
cups but just realize these are the most
important things out of everything so if
you just focus on these you're gonna be
in really good shape last point is the
liver takes a long time to rejuvenate I
mean it could take up to three years of
healthy eating yeah so have patients
keep putting in your house keep creating
house every single day and you will get
there thanks for watching